y llegan el derecho a la protesta las
autoridades cubanas no le concedieron a
activistas opositores el permiso para
llevar a cabo una gran marcha pacífica
el 15 de noviembre en la habana y otras
ciudades del país al considerarla
ilícita la marcha anunciada cuyo esquema
organizativo se concibe simultáneo para
otros territorios del país constituye
una provocación como parte de la
estrategia de cambio de régimen para
cuba ensayada en otros países los
críticos del gobierno organizados por un
grupo de facebook llamado archipiélago
inicialmente planearon protestas en todo
el país para el 20 de noviembre pero
decidieron cambiarla para el 15 de
noviembre fecha en que la isla planea
reabrirse al turismo tras casi dos años
de cierre ocasionado por la pandemia
júnior garcía actor y organizador de la
protesta dice que la marcha es un
derecho humano manifestarse de elección
dijeron que no va a respetar ese derecho
a pesar de que son de reforma bastante
que está en la constitución nos han
dicho que es ilícita nuestra solicitud
las protestas sacudieron el país durante
dos días en julio con las mayores
manifestaciones contra el gobierno en
décadas que resultaron en cientos de
arrestos una muerte y llamados a la
intervención de eeuu por parte de
algunos cubanoamericanos los
organizadores están estudiando si
mantienen o no la convocatoria